what's up guys i am finally announcing
another couple of dozen dates uh so if
you've been waiting every time i post if
you're like that's not where i'm from
that's not where i'm from this is your
time to pay attention they are on
pre-sale right now with promo code god
bless one word at salvocanocomedy.com
i'm going to be in hamilton uh i'm going
to be in toronto for the first time up
in canada richmond virginia hershey
pennsylvania all in october november
we're doing knoxville we're doing
atlanta
atlanta you've been you've been calling
on me babe i'm coming we're doing
birmingham we're doing uh i'm doing
evansville and louisville those are
rescheduled from the covet days and i'm
so excited to get to you guys
moving over to december guys we're going
to be in jacksonville tampa orlando
sacramento san jose and santa rosa those
are my dates right now the new dates
announced through the rest of the year
and then otherwise vegas july 15th is
gonna be a great one uh we're also in
boulder colorado um we are in phoenix
and then a great weekend over there in
portland seattle and vancouver so canada
i'm finally hitting you guys up florida
coming through uh you know north cali
i'm coming through all everything's
available this week and it's all on
salvolcanocomedy.com
check it out i hope to see you there
folks joe derosa here guess who's back
on the road officially the run
has almost
begun
i don't have a name for this run yet of
shows quite frankly i don't like what
people name their that doesn't matter
listen
here's where i'm headed july 9th
fairfield connecticut july 14-16 san
francisco california july or sorry
august 12th through 13th atlantic city
new jersey september 1st through 3rd san
diego california september 12th
somerville massachusetts and then dates
to follow in wilmington holland michigan
grand rapids michigan man i'm back out
there
go to joey
go to jotaro
fudge
go to rosa info.com go to
jodarossainfo.com
and you can get your tickets there for
most of the gigs and the ones that
aren't there yet will be there very soon
that's
joederosainfo.com for tickets also while
you are in new york city
you see it here we're in the rv at joey
roses come to joey rose's
in nyc the sandwich shop and bar for all
your sandwich and alcohol needs 174
rivington street we're open tuesday
through sunday
joeyrosesnyc.com for details thank you
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds buddies
welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buds we're here in the rose
room with joey roses once again doing
our show taste buds i'm joe derosa and
i'm salvatore volcano i'm originally
from staten island i'm 510 and i'm a
scorpio
beautiful now i don't know where this
drops in reference
to not reference i can tell you where it
drops right now because i'm all over
that [ __ ] i just mean it to in relation
to the hey babe that i was just on
uh
behavior that you were just on right we
wanted to the last one just the first
one today you're on the first the first
hey babe today drops on uh june 30th and
this episode is going to drop on june
27th okay so then you're looking into
the future
okay so then i need to tell the people
at home right now watching
that i'm in a lot of back pain at the
moment that's correct and uh i recorded
hey babe earlier today your back pain is
crossing over the podcast verse yes and
it seems to not be getting better
my condition seems to be worsening as i
go today yeah yeah uh i just dropped in
to see what condition my condition was
in who sings it babe kenny rogers all
right of course look it up if you don't
know it's a great tune yeah yeah yeah
what condition my condition was in so
i'm trying to get my spirits up mm-hmm
i'm always happy to see you
i'm always happy to see the podcast fans
out there but i'm in a bit of a mood
today i'm not gonna hide it i know you
are and i'm wondering how that's going
to affect our batelle uh yeah and i feel
bad a little bit i i feel that ari and
santino saw a little bit of the mood
come out i feel that chris saw a little
bit of the mood come out no but you
gotta you're being all hard on yourself
what i want you to do is i want you to
take a moment to be in this moment cast
that stuff aside just be here with me
you know for you know we'll do a 45-ish
or whatever it is just think about just
focus on your blt you know what i mean
let's just block everything out and just
think about a few things
bacon
lettuce lettuce tomato tomato that's
what i want you to do i want you to
smile i want you to take the edge off a
little bit and say you know what we're
in a safe zone now we are we really are
yeah and that's all it is yeah we really
are today no matter what happens i love
you day maybe it absolutely is
are you really serious
are you serious yeah would you tweak
your back i don't know what's going on
icy hot on that or something
yeah that would have been somebody's
enjoying a frosty beverage out there
that's pimp is is coming back in what
did seagram's diet ginger ale see grown
uh and uh
is that a seagram's pimp no just a
canada dry or regular you remember when
bruce willis was the spokesperson for
canada to draw no secrets
yeah he was he did a whole segregation
al jackson whose show you did today
daily blast live so i just got out of a
meeting with al about a different
project i swear to god no he didn't
right now today yeah i talked to him two
hours ago yeah when i i said i have to
shout out al jackson shout out shout out
jackson who you are the best i had i
said when i said i had to jump and you
all started making fun of me yeah he
heard that and then he started making
fun of me
and i said i'm sorry i have to go down
al jackson very
good friend very good great guy
but i said i'm sorry i have to go do my
hit podcast
and uh but i said i got to go talk to i
got to go talk to sal about cookies and
then he said sal was on my show today i
did i was going to make fun of you for
it uh fair enough i i did before full
disclosure before we did today i'm doing
press because the
the show starts well the show has
started the show started june 16th it's
on every thursday now pretty bad i got
to re i got to retake uh my promos there
was that we didn't say merch we didn't
say follow us on the live show i'm going
to retake it you guys will see you later
um
a little inside behind the scenery
behind the scenes yeah yes i did 20
bts's yeah i did 21 interviews before i
got here today
21 over four and a half hours you're a
soldier it sounds miserable it was rough
but it was i mean it's it's look it's a
blessing right no no no don't get right
wrong but it's a shame just scooping off
but it is like hard to do 21 in a row
and then come here today and do four
pods oh so so always yeah i mean that's
why i feel bad even complaining a little
bit too bad my back doesn't hurt um but
but but
you just brought up the bruce willis
seagram's thing yeah
al told me on the phone just now
uh we were talking about cult 45 sure
more liquor yeah and we really did well
yeah that's all we were talking about
billy williams like i had forgotten he
was the spokesperson oh yeah man yeah
how great is that great like billy d
williams is a suave smooth talking actor
that play lando calrissian
he was in the last star wars movie
yes he was right yeah yeah what's he
been up to though outside of that you're
pleased with him
what's your daily day like if you billy
d i think he's just living life i want
to just live life though he gave the
greatest answer when when they made solo
and donald glover played lando
and they said do you think donald will
be able to capture your swagger and he
goes nobody can capture my sword
and that's the most swagger thing you
could say and he wasn't like being funny
he was being like
he was perplexed yeah like what are you
talking about
what is this capturing of swag are you
speaking babe do it popcorn really
nobody did it
if you i'm trying to do this before i'm
trying to numb up more of a like a water
to me at this yeah i'm trying to numb up
here
i know
oh yeah pimp what kind of sandwich
you're eating
i got a turkey blt with turkey bacon
first of all gel second of all wow
a turkey blt now don't go and tout the
blt because when you add the t it's not
a blt
that's basically a club yeah that's a
club stand which and i'll say this
before we would
sal is representing bec whoo
i'm going to learn everybody
sounds replication
[Laughter]
shout out oakland i couldn't
as a hip-hop fan brooklyn yeah oakland i
believe so yeah
what wait where are they from compton
oh yeah because they were on board
oakland
well shout out to
houston yes shout out get a boys willy d
scarface r.i.p bushwick this year
halloween fell on a weekend um
but
it's why and big mike
gotta was then dj ready red i know all
the numbers johnny c prince jukebox i
know everybody uh anyway uh
the uh
when thuggish ruggish bone came out is
the duggar's rugged bone i couldn't make
head or ass out of that i didn't know
what was going on i almost don't
understand crossroads either says
cleveland cleveland oh that's right
yeah my bed bone thugs but like when
that beat started and that lady started
singing and then they came in rapping
the way they did it i was like what the
[ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah and it took first of the
month was one where i was like
i caught like the rhythm of it like i
was like okay
are they cleveland's biggest act
i mean cleveland is where the rock and
roll hall of fame is there's probably a
lot of huge
hip-hop
though oh is he really
i don't know yeah i guess he's i guess
he's
i can't i don't know how to compare him
to bone thugs i don't really know
you know because he is also like the
little i don't think he's a radio play
right per se
oh mgk yeah he's the biggest artist out
right now no no but now with the pop
stuff but when he had to lace up stuff
wasn't he like underground a bit he was
smaller right yeah so just in a hip-hop
perspective although bone studs didn't
have that many hits
he's big though
i know he's famous but i didn't know
super headliner i felt like his music
wasn't like as big as his like person
took uh paramore sound and brought back
like pop punk
he runs shut up machine gun kelly so
wait he's doing he's not rapping anymore
he does like a mix of rap emails i heard
he's going back ugh it's all a hybrid
yeah yeah
i saw a video with him is it good long
time ago
i saw a video of him a long time ago and
it was i think like it was a video of
him sitting in a house with a couple of
friends little apartment or whatever and
it was like the first time he was either
on the news or they heard his his song
on the radio or something and he had
they captured on camera it was pretty
moving i tell her i don't know much
about him but he intrigued me but i saw
that video and it was it was i really
actually it stuck with me
he seemed very very very
thankful did you ever see the uh rush
documentary beyond the lighted stage i
have not
i'm a big rush fan so i really enjoyed
it time rush yeah
but they have footage of them these guys
were around literally 60 years or
something
they have footage of them sitting at a
neil parker one of their parents yeah
one of their parents dinner tables
when they're like 17
in like i guess it's like the late 60s
early 70s on the edge of
seventeen oh no yeah that's not them
though she's only seven but it's crazy
like they're sitting at the dinner table
and they once had one of those
yeah and they have video footage
of them sitting as teenagers being like
and the parents being like why do you
guys want to be a band wow and this and
alex lives in being like i just think
why do i have to go get like when am i
going to be an accountant like what it's
crazy that that's on tape
tell me who's exists ready
rush
rush hurry hurry
i didn't think you were going to get
that and also your back hurts and you i
couldn't get this it's a huge song i
know but i don't put you you don't i
don't think she's on your radar please
but it wasn't one of her bigger hits
yes it was i i said rush and you cut me
off
i'm i am surprised
zoom in pimp and look at me when he says
it that was her like time after time
oh what a song we're trying to get cindy
lopez on the show
on joker's oh that'd be cool i mean
we're trying we're reaching cindy lauper
if you're watching and we know that you
are you're going to watch this but not
do that share the love come on in
practical jokers wait what does she
watch she watches this well we know that
she's watching shh
likes taste buds oh yeah
i don't know if you're just
no but joe it's just the thing i've been
doing for a couple of years no big deal
no no cindy lawrence if you're watching
and we know that you are
oh oh oh i see it's a bit
but let me tell you something right now
that's her time at the time oh true
colors
either
when kodak bought true colors yes yeah
it's where
it's
it's when abdul went valid it's when
abdul went ballad you know but shout out
pull up to my friend who actually just
came to see me perform the other day
have you had her i mean she was in the
movie she's in the movie and she's gonna
be in season 10. okay right on baby we
got some really cool guests for season
we have like fun [ __ ] coming right on
the pike that's great we got uh
blake anderson from workaholics we got
john mayer yeah we got kesha
oh we got anthony davis from the lakers
i knew about kesha yeah we got we got
some real cool people coming on that's
interesting yeah that's very cool so
isn't that weird that is kesha a joker's
fan um we're we're we have connections
to her
very interesting she's amazing but um we
share a manager
ah that well still yeah very interesting
yeah do you guys see what happened to
justin bieber's face yeah yeah that's
wild
yeah like that he got like something he
might be done he might be done no i he i
i i heard it was temporary paralysis
well they said there's smaller it's like
belle's palsy but worse and they said
there's a lesser chance of your face or
it takes away longer but i mean you
could have belt
we hope he gets out but but i mean if
he's i mean he has a billion bucks to
throw at it so hopefully
yeah i feel bad for him in the video
when he's like his eyes are going like
it's yeah i would be i would be scared
he seemed pretty
he seemed pretty composed
that would yes i would not be able to
make that video i would be in pure
hysterics
and you would have to come to where i
was and you'd have to calm
down you know there was fans who were
and i'm not me
like get out there i bought a ticket
yeah that's what i feel you guys if
you're watching you can't do that also
there was definitely people saying awful
tater [ __ ] i mean it's just disgusting
he's come a long way what a disgusting
world we live in you know i was at a
nightclub one time and he was there and
he was literally riding his skateboard
around the dance floor oh my god how old
is she now
she's 65 70.
what is it is he even 30 no i don't
think he is
my favorite bieber thing is when he
signed anne frank's uh they had like a
book in her yeah
yeah
yes oh we had the tv he was so good he
did uh i bet you would be a fan of mine
yes yeah
i mean it's amazing though i i bet you
she he went and visited the thing and he
signed the book and i i bet she would be
a justin bieber fan which like it's just
hysterical like i get really what he was
like i don't know
i don't think he realized how funny that
was going to sound because you're gone
you're at that point you're gone
yeah but if you show that
i know he said another
that's also like just saying like i bet
i bet abe lincoln would have been a
taste buds fan
and then you're signing that at like at
the [ __ ] wilkes booth one thing one
thing instrumental
to most famous people
and their success
is
you know especially at that level
they get surrounded by these shaman and
advice givers and all these things that
start telling them things like you
needn't apologize for your success you
need to and you know it's a beautiful
thing so they start to think like in his
head
i'm back guessing
writing something like that is putting
positivity into the universe you know
what i mean you lose all sense of that's
a little dildoy bro you know like like
because nobody's going to tell you that
but a little dildo is fun for people
sometimes
or maybe he was trying to be funny
maybe did you see oh you know what i
just watched i was on adam ray shout out
adam ray buddy adam right i was just on
adam's podcast love him and uh we we
pulled up did you ever see the justin
bieber deposition
we're not we don't have a television
today because we're in the rose room but
you gotta when you leave here today you
gotta put in justin bieber that position
and watch it it is you will lose your
[ __ ] why it's so funny dude it's when he
was a little younger and still a little
bit like you know he was he was like a
little bit more arrogant and immature
but it was also when he was like really
being hounded by the paparazzi and i
guess he got brought in for
whatever thing he did maybe racing his
car whatever the hell it was and they
had to on like on camera the lawyers had
to like grill him about all these
questions and he was having none of it
and he was like literally like trying to
put them in their place through the
whole thing but it was his dude it's i i
can't do it justice all right he was
like he would he would be like he was
giving them such a hard time they were
like were you there on ireland he's like
don't ever talk to me like that again
don't ever talk to me about that again
and then he would look at the they're
talking to him he's looking at the
camera he's going
he's fixing his hair and stuff
it's awesome
is little wayne you ever seen that one
too little threatening i went on like a
tear i judged i went on like a
deposition tear after that you did
you're just going to little wayne
lil wayne was like he was like he was
pissed
to watch her
yeah wow yeah that's why shout out
wheezy he's the best yeah i'm a fan of a
little he's one of the best he's
he's a top 10 mc of all time maybe he's
still doing it would you agree he's a
great rap he's not in my top
he's gotta be in top 10. my i have a
list of my top 20. he's not on it he's
not that's no disrespect he's put him in
that top five that's no different
that's that's he's the man i'm talking
about like
there's just too many yeah i'll read you
my list you wanna hear my list please i
got a list here's the order of the
listeners of the girl he got all the
money he made though he signed drake
reggie and drake you know the list tupac
and biggie
from outcast jada corrupt nas and that
means
you know what i really wish though i
really wish andre 3000
would continue his body at work
all right here's my top 20.
ready you
i'm sorry you have your top 20 mc's
written in your photos i should have my
list here
is it a is it a is it a a is it is it a
list that evolves or is it no this is my
top 20. you thought about it yeah so you
you literally long and hard you
literally like 17 is better than 19.
well i wouldn't say there any in in any
particular order outside of the first
three okay
but let me guess your first three
rock him
not in that order
but he's in the first three yes
yes very good okay you're not going to
paco biggie i don't think
you're going we're talking just mc's
right
i know that you're an old head
i don't think you're going krs-1 you'd
be wrong you did go get number one well
well there you go i am i'm really good
he's very good he's not number one ice
cube is my number two rock kim's my
number three ice cube yes
yes
very important very important and very
good
i agree i agree i just uh and then from
there it's random so sean price
tupac eminem
scarface
cool g rap method man dmx
nas big l
busta rhymes big daddy kane
biggie jay-z red man cool mo d inspector
deck corrupt
i mean everyone on there is a killer
it's hard dude i believe a lot of people
i loved off of it you know which is the
conversation you have with yourself
no i actually i wanna i gotta leave them
off i gotta leave them off i gotta i was
going back and forth with dante uh nero
sure sure for days about this yeah shout
out dante nero shout out to their man
weighs a ten pound earring it's
unbelievable and i kept revising my list
yeah based on our conversation and this
is what i finally landed on i was like
all right i honestly think these are the
20 greatest
in my opinion
yeah people put scarface in it
did you say you didn't say poc no he was
on there he was on there people put
who did you not put that's normally put
on there did you say lil wayne no oh you
just told me that's the impetus of the
conversation i'm trying to think of who
you might have missed
uh if you think cube is seminal
then
anyone else from that are you did you
say dre
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
um
let me think about this now did you say
snoop
no
no snoop is a great artist he is nowhere
near a great rapper
you know what i mean he's got flow he's
got swagger he's got he's he's there's
not many people like him he's unique his
sound or anything but as far as like
actual rhymes go
right yeah no it's it's you know like
you said modi
he's he's one of the greats yeah in the
music game but i do not think like i
picked guys where i was like if i put
these guys on a stage to battle
every one of these guys is going to come
full [ __ ] fangs nobody from ep you
didn't say it no i'm the ep is my
favorite rap group of all time like but
they're not they're not in they're not
battling they said i met keith murray
keith murray is great
he's a fan but nowhere near again oh he
knew the show i should say i respect i
respect the hell out of him though a lot
of these guys
i have different types of rappers i love
like like a guy like snoop to me eric
sermon i love eric storman like snoop
and epmd and apmd is my favorite of all
time
they're like whole package rappers to me
like where it's like there's a whole
vibe
their lyrics i agree like lords of the
underground will like that yeah like
it's very related to the sound
it's so it's like a whole thing well
then there are other guys where it's
like you you could put like you put like
rock cam over a click track
right and it's going to be like insane
you know i i would like to know more
about pete rock
and c.l smooth but i i i know you know
i don't know that they're deep tracks or
anything like that
like even like like i think dmc and run
are instrumental yeah i don't think
they're anywhere near the greatest
rappers right right but they're amazing
yeah you know so it's not an insult when
they say that what do you guys think
about kendrick lamar he's like the
greatest he's fantastic
he's really great i mean as far as mt's
like literally working right now he's
got he's
he's arguably the best i think his music
videos might be the best ever shot like
they're really interesting i gotta you
know he's someone i'm always like i
gotta i have to
i had to listen to his music more
i respect him so much especially in the
state that i could say the state that
hip-hop is in because it's not for me
right now really but he's someone that
is still doing his own thing anderson
park i really like to be strictly a
rapper but like i just saw silk sonic in
vegas yeah it was it it he decided him
and uh bruno mars had an album together
holy jesus christ i went to
their their concert
in vegas at the park
i'm telling you man it was one of the gr
it was one of the best shows i have seen
in like 10 years
it was
undeniable
he is so talented they both are
bruno mars this generation's like
michael j beyond it i think he's better
than him he is so good
he is so you can't even hate on them top
40 not throwing that out the window
anderson pack will play eight
instruments oh yeah and they did they
all played all the insurance but also
like you can't hate on bruno mars he is
so authentic and so [ __ ] i i mean
he's like that
you watch him and you're just like he
just talked about sweat like you just oh
like i wish
i could be that cool
and he's really nice i got to meet him
i'd say this story i told i probably
tell the story on the podcast
oh wait no yeah you did yeah yeah i met
him at a club one night and then he was
like oh a fan i was like he's like we
watch you on the bus and then he invited
us to his concert the next night he
shattered us out from the stage and
stuff but dude that dude is
i wish i could wear like a suit like
that like a maroon suit with a big
collar with chains with a freaking hat
sideways some boots please just like
that i wish i
i wish i could i think i looked like an
eggplant or something
what's up guys let's talk about butcher
box you know we love them over there if
you don't know what butcher box is it is
a subscription service that delivers
the best in meat chicken fish seafood i
mean free range organic wild caught
grass-fed beef all that stuff
to your house new subscribers can get a
free grilling bundle on their first
order right now uh i like it because you
don't have to worry about choosing meats
at the grocery store i need any kind of
proteins at the grocery store you know
you're getting top quality stuff it
comes frozen i believe is that right
yes
it is frozen i just want to make sure
that for convenience it's packed fresh
ship frozen uh save money uh on trips to
the the grocery store save time on trips
to the grocery store every month
butcherbox ships a curated selection of
the high quality meat right to your home
free shipping in the continental united
states no antibiotics no hormones um you
can customize your own box if you want
to you could order one from theirs you
could
actually
i believe you can pause yes you can
pause your subscription whenever you
want which i think is the coolest thing
uh
it's kind of like a no-brainer it's a
really cool thing
to uh
to have at your fingertips you know what
i mean
uh what it's less than six bucks per
meal on average so you're gonna save
money there um
yeah butcher box if you guys have heard
us talk about before and i don't know if
you guys like hear us uh talk about it i
know how many of you take action but
this is one of those ones that i
actually they sent me my first one and
then after that i was like oh this is
too good not to not to have all the time
so i am an actual customer of butcher
box
i think that you'd like it to get summer
sizzling uh
get summer sizzling started with this
special butcher box deal for our
listeners slash viewers free bacon for
life which is the funniest thing i've
ever heard but it's true
plus membership uh ten dollars off your
membership sign up at butcherbox.com
taste buds use the code taste buds to
get one pack of free bacon in every
single box for the life of your
membership with them so if you have a
membership till the day you pass
that bacon is coming every month until
the day that you pass plus ten dollars
of your first order that's butchbox.com
tastebuds and use code buds to claim
this deal butcher box
guys it is harder than ever at least for
me to exercise these days my schedule is
crazy i don't want to do it when i come
home at the end of the day i don't want
to wake up three hours early to do it
you know and go to the gym before i
leave uh and on the road i'm on the road
a lot i i when i get to the hotel after
traveling the last thing i want to do is
be like let me set aside a couple of
hours to go down to the gym or whatever
and
last september i got myself a peloton it
sits right in my home and the classes
can be anywhere from 20 to 30 minutes 10
minutes anything you want customize
those classes it's not just bike riding
they have all sorts of stuff like yoga
you could join live classes or archive
pre-tape classes you can find uh
someone leading the class that you like
so all the different instructors they
have all different styles they play all
different types of playlists the music
is awesome so you get the energy like
you actually in the class but you don't
have to be and it's as convenient as
possible i jump on right before i go in
the shower 20 minutes boom i'm done i
feel good about myself for that day uh
you know about pelton you know the name
everyone's has a peloton these days if
you don't i don't know i think you
should at least look into it that's what
i'm saying um what else what else what
else
uh
running running two and i did you do
this thing i like one of the things i
like is that you can
look there's a there's like a
3d virtual thing where you could put in
a location and while you're cycling or
running you can actually navigate
through a place that you've never been
to before and it's it's really actually
that's my favorite feature on the whole
thing uh peloton is a team of
world-class instructors ready to
motivate you it's 24 7. they're highly
trained fitness pros they motivate that
is for sure um
whatever your fitness level peloton has
an instructor for you they don't just
teach they motivate there's thousands of
live and on-demand classes like i
mentioned so things keep fresh strength
training yoga running uh
it fits seamlessly into your life maybe
you're looking for that 10-minute upper
body stretch between calls or the
40-minute run before bed and you'll
never have an awkward encounter in the
locker room again which i really skipped
the locker rooms when i used to go to
the gym because there's a lot of stuff
going on in there that i don't need to
really see right now is the perfect time
to try out peloton the peloton bike plus
is 500 less it's the best price yet
including free delivery and setup they
bring it right into your house they drop
it where you want it they set it up they
were really professional when they did
that there are more game changing uh
prices available on the original peloton
bike as well and the peloton trend so
check it out visit
onepeloton.com to learn more
but santino just uh just finished he
said okay i assume that means he's
heading back all right that's nice of
him so so but he's is he going to jump
what's he going to do i don't know if
i'm coming or going today i don't know
yeah you don't know we should start
let's do the all right so what we're
battling today is and you brought this
to me and i said i'll take that bet
is blt which is a baking lettuce and
tomato versus a bacon egg and cheese
which is bacon egg and cheese which is
called the bec actually especially now
here's the thing that we said we thought
it was a good battle they're both bacon
based sandwiches bacon forward-based
sandwiches we think that the blt
is probably more popular
on a larger scope
and we suspect that as
as lights out as a bacon egg and cheese
is to new yorkers it might not be that
popular
around the country and so we thought it
was a a good battle to go up against you
now
our buddy said that they thought that
you were gonna cream souped on this one
yeah ari said that yeah did chris say
that too i think they said yeah he said
yeah he said you're gonna get all right
so show a couple things
couple things ari is nuts
sure institutionally nuts yeah
chris is trash
pig trash i know you asked but i could
see what you're saying most people yeah
most people if you ask
so i don't count either of their their
weigh-ins uh at all you know ari ari
would eat if if you left it to ari to
his own devices he would eat like
popcorn for dinner
yeah so his opinion doesn't count also
he he didn't bake until he was like 30.
right chris uh i've seen have
65 order orders of carvel delivered to
his house
i don't count their why don't they why
don't their opinions stand on this this
battle though because i think that okay
let's start it sorry okay
b a t t l e butts all right so i b
here's why because i don't think
that
i just don't think look whether or not
the b you just don't think well i was
gonna i don't
but whether or not
the bacon egg and cheese is worthwhile
he's leaning forward folks he's leaning
forward uh or quality or whatever it's
besides the point i just don't think the
opinions
of two men like that count in any way
whether they were supporting me or
support here's where i am confused about
this battle right now you are
you're basically a new yorker i mean i
know you're philly and i know you moved
around but you're a new yorker you're i
would just call you a new yorker
the bacon egg and cheese is like to us
is like the mascot of the bodega it's
like it is
every morning you start your morning off
right with the bacon egg and cheese it's
like it represents new york city i have
a there was a clothing brand that sent
me a t-shirt
my girl shay gave me a t-shirt that said
i'm a i'm a i'm a bacon egg and cheese
kid and it was like this this new york
like streetwear brand
i don't know how you think that
a bacon lettuce and tomato is going to
compete well because
everybody doesn't live in new york
and i i've cut the bacon out of egg and
cheese out of my life
completely no no it was never a big part
of my life are you serious
there's nothing better in the morning
when you're a little hungry and you bite
into a bacon
egg there it is i'll tell you what it is
i like american cheese it's melting the
egg is scrambled it's still piping hot
and that bacon is burnt babe and it's on
you know do it on a roll but you can
have it on anything and if i can have it
on a biscuit watch out if i can have
something i'll say what's nine times
better ham egg and cheese nine times
better ham cheese sausage egg and cheese
mcdonald's joe you bet didn't you battle
for bacon in a battle or did i no i
battled sausage oh you did when
mcdonald's dropped their breakfast menu
bacon wasn't even on the goddamn thing
it was the mcmuffin how do we know
you're going to bring up
because it's the greatest restaurant of
all time
they had they had the ham egg and cheese
was the staple that was the mcmuffin and
then later came the sausages
but why are you in there
but why you but you bacon is on your
sandwiches
hold on a second but when they brought
bacon egg and cheese into the mix i
didn't even i paid it no mind i never
got it even when i was a big breakfast
sandwich guy i never got bacon egg and
cheese i don't think it's a salad
sandwich but you're leading with that
bacon wasn't on their menu but bacon is
the main ingredient in your sandwich as
well the blt is disappearing against
bacon
superior sandwich it's not a sausage egg
sausage lettuce in tomato i know but the
bacon up against lettuce tomato and a
little bit of mayonnaise sometimes
avocado okay
is a superior sandwich it's a better mix
not a blta
okay fine if i just even go basic with
the toast dude you get a [ __ ] rye
toast
bacon lettuce tomato a little bit of
mayonnaise with with like the crisp
bacon but with a little bit of give to
it
the shredded lettuce or sometimes you
get leaves of butter lettuce crispy
shredded lettuce with that little bit of
uh with the it's cold and crispy i look
i get the value of a blt but like we
were saying before off cam let's put
these head to head a choice of bread on
both wash
bacon on both wash
now we're getting down to the nitty
gritty i'll tell you why i don't know
i'm gonna go egg right against tomato
strike one and cheese
strawberries
let's hold on santino's calling hold on
what's up poor
did you find food that fits your [ __ ]
palate finally
oh wow wow wow
wow
we're we're almost done come on down
we're not almost done bye pudgy
i lied
[Laughter]
by the time he gets down here i let him
go yeah yeah um
strike one is your egg
strike one is your egg strike two is
your cheese a bacon egg and cheese is
all grease
it is all grease it gives me a
stomachache dude you need something to
lighten up that load of bacon bacon is
so greasy man
bacon is on your sandwich i know
that's what i'm saying you need
something to lighten its load take you
serious in this battle i want to but you
just said strike two is your cheese
bro cheese makes the world rotate on
that sandwich she on that sandwich yes
are you okay no my back is killing me i
know but you look like there's a host of
problems my back is killing me look fans
look what i'm doing for all of you right
now don't say i never delivered it don't
say i don't care you know what
i saw like
so the nade episode
uh part two was this week i saw in the
comments i don't always see everything
but i saw in the comments what are you
doing they said just make it one episode
why are you breaking it up on us into
two episodes just make it one episode
like we don't need two episodes we just
just put it in one what do you what are
you doing you're turning on us we are
giving you a year and a half free
completely free entertainment
fitting it into our own schedules guys
we don't have the we me i fit this in in
between everything because we love it
it's a passion project yeah and we want
to give it to you guys and this is the
people saying telling us what to do we
got two hours of content we can't meet
again you guys get an hour a week you're
gonna tell us you need to give us two
and get testy with us well then we don't
need you around here that drove me crazy
guys i'm here right now and so we don't
agree a lot i'm here right now in severe
back pain because this was literally the
only slot for weeks that we could record
i did 21 interviews before this podcast
but wait but wait let me give you both
uh so i had to find another day to treat
we have us we have a fight i gave you a
free show a finite period of time we can
record in given the schedules we fit as
much as we can in that time we we had to
get three episodes done
in that window we only worked and we
opened and the one went long so we made
it two parts not that we had to don't
want ourselves themselves comment i saw
that made me furious
and i believe it was a woman that wrote
this if i'm remembering correctly
i'm just because i'm going to say she or
whatever but but i'm about to apologize
if i'm not using the right pronouns
whatever
but
this person wrote
you know guys
you need to warn us when it's going to
be a
to be continued
because i spend my commute listening to
this podcast
and i waited the whole drive for a
battle and i didn't get it
please be kind enough to warn us next
time when the battles
are you out of your [ __ ] sucking your
audio
bird by the way what are you talking
about all the lovely fans who appreciate
the free content and had nothing to say
about positivity
yes you guys please thank you positivity
door is always open to you guys but my
point is it is funny for people to bark
at us how
they want us to present this sounds here
after 21 interviews two episodes of hey
babe i'm here with i've been sitting
here by the way through all of i did one
episode of hey babe i had opened the bar
for pimp and i got back pain and i'm
here where you're here we're here for
christ's sake don't turn this around and
say that we're complaining right now all
we're doing is shedding a little light
on your complaints
anyway bacon neck and cheek
my point is buddy bacon is great
nobody's saying it's not but when you
put it onto a sandwich even with a bacon
cheeseburger okay which is all grease i
don't love a bacon cheeseburger i need
too much the produce on there i have to
offset this thing
produce unfortunately in my opinion does
not go on a bacon egg and cheese i've
seen some other animals put it on i
think it's insane
but um
but i just think of bacon a good cheese
and look i get it a sausage egg and
cheese also is a full-on stomachache
sandwich it's all grease but the flavor
of it is much better to me i don't i
think really that much grease on a bacon
egg and cheese outside of the bacon
the eggs dude greasy eggs
i have like new york in new york you're
getting you're getting that flat top
cooked egg that they cook in oil or
butter and then put right on there it's
greasy
sometimes that egg is burnt and it's
gross and it's like brown there are
certain things in our life
that just go together and they are
better than the sum
of their parts no they're better i i
always get this saying wrong you know
what i mean
chocolate and peanut butter
french fries and ketchup
sauce and cheese right what i'm saying
a bacon egg and cheese you bite into
that thing and that is
an old timer it's an all-timer
combination of three flavors plus the
bread that is just like
it's almost like having you coffee some
to people like i i don't know man i just
it's it's it's it's a it's a staple
grand slam breakfast option it's i think
it's an undeniable i think it's
undeniable as a matter of fact i don't
know if i've ever unless people are
adverse to eggs or lactose intal
i i don't know if i've ever met some
reason i find bacon
with breakfast with breakfast
a meat that i don't want on the roll i
want it on the plate next to something
else i don't know why that is but it's
just something with breakfast breakfast
is already heavy enough
piling up all that's all the stuff that
you would have on the plate separately
then on to bread
i'm just like huh however for whatever
reason a blt
refreshing
light
i don't even like a turkey club that
much like i think the turkey club ruins
the blt concept because it adds too much
crap to it
there's something very light like on a
day where i'm very hungry i want
something substantial but i don't want
to feel weighed down i get a blt it hits
the spot i'm moving
the blt
you don't see it on a lot of menus
not a lot of people make it at home
it's a once in a while type of sandwich
it's it's like oh i remember blts exist
and then you're like i'm gonna it's been
a year since i've had a blt i'll have a
blt and that's fine it's it's tasty when
you have it and you remember it once a
year but compare that to the one that's
running through your mind almost every
morning when the roosters [ __ ] a doodle
do
you know what i mean you're getting up
and you're going i have some options for
breakfast today i can have a pancake
some cereal i could have some eggs but i
could combine
the egg people put eggs and then bacon
in the same you're eating the same thing
you got a piece of toast you got eggs
and you got bacon and you're just eating
them one at a time put them all together
for a swift kick in the breakfast nuts
let's not pretend let's not sit here and
pretend like you're getting a bacon egg
and cheese on toast most of the time
nine times out of ten a b b e c is
coming on a kaiser roll nine times out
of ten and if you're taking a baby if
i'm at home i'm putting it on if i'm at
home putting on an english muffin i'm
calling it a day and by the way on a
biscuit
on a business i don't even know who i am
anymore biscuit ain't no life piece of
bread
i didn't say a biscuit it was no light
piece of bread but i'm just saying this
is a heavy sandwich this is a lot of
times people put a blt on the thick the
thick bread by the way the hala bread or
whatever it's called
holla bread well whatever you mean
sourdough no no they put it on a thick
bread bro
i've never seen well i don't maybe maybe
i've seen it but i don't know man
you know what it is it's like the bacon
in the blt you can't have the blt
without the bacon you could have an egg
and cheese without the bacon you want to
see what i'm saying bacon is it bacon is
behind the wheel you don't no one has a
bread with lettuce and tomato nobody
does that you that's it so you're
hinging everything on the bacon i have
the bacon i have your secret ingredient
in mine but my sandwich can exist
without the bacon and also i don't
necessarily know
while it is good if bacon lettuce and
tomato as a triad
come together to blow my balls off
whereas like i said before i think you
close your eyes you bite into a a bacon
an egg and a cheese and honestly it
tastes like the morning it tastes like
what breakfast is supposed to taste like
i don't know man i i think i would i
would i would venture to say more people
crave it
because it's an everyday type of food
then people crave a blt i'll go a step
further i find breakfast to be the most
useless meal on planet earth when
popular convention says it's the most
important oh well let popular convention
whatever popular minch wants to say
i love that you had a cough like a 100
year old man
in the middle of talking about a popular
convention
see what the messes won i'll be gone
soon
i might be
i don't feel right
i don't want you to feel that way but do
you think i feel warm do you want to
feel me oh come on dude don't do this to
me
first of all you mess up babe you are
clean don't you worry about it how do
you know i'm clean you're
because you have antibodies
you had my hand three weeks ago no i had
it in april
dude i had it in april you have this
anybody's for six months don't you know
how this works yeah now there's all
strains now it's like marijuana fine
feel my head tell me if i'm warm
i don't know if i want to pimp can you
feel my head
look at this this is a friend yeah but
he's a young kid credit karma you know
what it's about let me tell you
something i wish i had credit karma when
i was 18 because i went to college i
remember the first week i went to
college you could apply for a credit
card they had a table set up and i did
and it was the worst choice i've ever
made it was a 23 apr it was only a 500
limit for a college kid
i maxed it out quickly and then i just
felt suffocated for years after that
trying to pay like their minimums all
the time i didn't have anyone to guide
me and nowadays you have something like
credit karma which is a really useful
tool to use if you want a credit card
but you're not sure how to choose you
don't need to apply for the first card
you get in the mail or the first card
you see in the courtyard at college
credit karma can help you zero in on the
right option for you and apply with more
confidence have you ever been rejected
for a credit card it happens way too
often that's why credit karma created
karma confidence technology that has a
nice ring to it helping our members
apply with more confidence you want to
be educated when you apply for a line of
credit guys you want to know what you're
getting into and you don't want to just
do it alone and just sign away something
you don't realize what a big mistake or
a big choice you're making sometimes i
didn't at 18 when i applied for a credit
card i was just like oh my god i feel
like an adult now
are you earning credit card rewards uh
credit karma can help you compare your
award options so you can find a card
that fits your lifestyle helping you
earn more miles through your lifestyle
and how you spend or cash back for
spending that you're going to do anyway
they use your credit profile to show you
offers that are tailored to your
financial situation they partner with a
wider range of all the different card
issuers so you can be sure you're
exploring all your options best of all
they use your credit data to show you
your chances of approval before you even
apply so you're not wasting your time
and you're applying with more confidence
comparing cards on credit karma is uh
100 free and it will not affect your
credit score that's another thing i was
always worried about because back then
you always heard that every card you
look into or apply to
you will get hit on your credit score
because they check and that's and it was
like this catch 22. it will not affect
it credit karma create your own karma
ready to find the card for you head to
credit karma and check out your
personalized mix of offers offers today
go to
creditkarma.com or the credit karma app
to find the card for you that's
creditkarma.com
guys
life is too short to not be having fun
24 7. uh i have some lulls in my day
when i'm traveling when i'm eating a
sandwich things of that nature i'm like
i'm not having a good time right now and
i want to say something i used to rent
these game when you when back when you
rented games for your consoles i used to
rent one called vegas dreams and i
thought it was the coolest thing in the
world it was like this interactive
storytelling game where you can go to
all the the casinos and you could play
just for fun and rack up money and all
that stuff and
there's nothing more satisfying than the
thrill i don't do it often because i'm
nervous but there's nothing more
satisfying than the thrill of hitting
even in the game just a jackpot i don't
do in real life but in the jackpot i
just think it's the best thing in the
world sladomania is a new game it's not
a gambling app at all it's just for fun
um that it is a hundred percent it's a
free slots game that you can now play
like right on your phone you'll have
endless excitement at your fingertips
they have 170
free free-to-play slot games with huge
jackpots in an interactive community and
millions of free coins it's just an
escape for your daily routine a lot of
us are playing these app games you know
and you're crushing things and you're
angry at things and things like that
this is just fun it's like cool graphics
they make it really fun there's a slot
community so you could talk to other
people again it's just the game it's a
unique gaming experience graphics are
awesome there's high progressive slots
fun freebies mini games an endless
variety of stuff
get a little meat time uh i i like it on
the commute that's what i like it a fun
mix of casino gaming and casual gaming
at any time aurora is a pet cheetah on
this thing that helps you win mega
jackpots and prizes
while you take care of her it's so silly
but it's so much fun um
join the biggest community of slot
lovers in the world interact with fellow
players and form cooperative slaughter
clans you've heard of the wu-tang clan
this is a slatto clan with new friends
uh join live tournaments become a vip
member to get your own personal account
manager connect with millions of other
slot fans on slottamania's facebook page
the biggest slots community in the world
share your wins with the world get love
and feedback from other members 24 7.
again it's just a game my grandma used
to play slots all the time she loved it
and so i kind of like it because it
reminds me of her that's just something
for me to do you don't have to think
about your grandmother when you play
slaughter mania um when your day is
feeling stale just ask what will today
spin if you're 21 or older you can join
millions of players around the world
download slotted mania the number one
free slots uh
game on the app store or the google play
store and get a million free coins to
start with that's slotted mania on the
app store or the google play store for
one million free coins check it out
look at this this is a friend yeah but
he's a young kid
oh come on now i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna get covered a third
time over bacon you can't get it this
close to the last time you had it yeah
you're shouting at me
you're shouting at me i'm warm because
i'm dehydrated
yeah dehydrated raises your body temp so
why do you have a miller in front of you
because i drank a bunch of water at
lunch and it's not doing anything and i
was like maybe i'll slip it here pounded
water
you're not dehydrated anymore
no no i am no you're out gallivanting
all weekend you're at you're at this bar
you're you're a real ball you're at
another ball you're meeting up you're
being very social you're going to
concert you're doing this you're doing
that i didn't go to any concerts but you
do do that no i don't
you'll go to i ain't been to a concert
in years
that's an outright lie no it's not
you've been the cop you're thinking of
jay you're thinking of jay you didn't
come with us the krung ban radio city
you son of a [ __ ] you were there i took
you we went to a show made me go you
said you weren't at a concert in two
years i forgot about that one did you
see that [ __ ] show jay's going to see
tonight he's going to see i it was it
tonight he's going to see uh train
blues traveler and jewel at the pnc no
that was last night and then and then
last week he goes to see coldplay
i'm like what are you what are you doing
jay i said you're on a concert tear and
he wrote concerts are back bro but you
can't wear fingerless gloves to see
coldplay and jewel he did it can't do
that he did it can't do that you know
something about jewel that nobody knows
she used to live in a car nobody knows
that no everybody literally everybody
knows that i know and that's why
that's why i'm making a joke sorry well
i don't he's explaining my joke it's
probably your card it's probably because
you're back
probably couldn't know painting
fact about jewel nobody knows she used
to live in a car he said every single
person you should have just laughed at
that and said that's a good one i hope i
have covered i hope you
i honestly if you have covert i think
that i could probably sue you maybe you
cannot sue me yeah because you think you
might have kova you're sitting right
here you tell me not to worry this is an
assault i think i might have covet i
think i'm an assault i think i'm
dehydrated i just don't don't come to
the rose room oh yeah yeah i think you
need another shot why don't you do
it's gonna make another show
worse
he's dehydrated and just do shots
i'm sorry i'm having a tough day today i
know you are you had a bad day is that
training if you had a bad day not the
best day
all you gotta say do a sate
oh my god i don't know i don't know i
don't know how to explain him imagine
trying to explain to someone who's never
met him it's impossible it's impossible
to explain this man to someone who's
never met him i hope when aliens land
they meet their own they meet derozan
then they're going to have a big
misconception that's why you love me
it is why i love you but
you are you're fading away you want a
plane jane as a friend you're sliding
down the dick you're doing shots your
back hurts you dehydrating you have a
fever you're doing shots i don't know
actually we're laying down help you why
don't you lay down
i might need to do that in the next
episode no i'm i'm super nervous i
cannot get sick bro shall i you have
antibodies and i don't have covid but so
if you don't have covert i don't have
those antibodies i don't have a [ __ ]
fever or a floor advice i don't i don't
have it what do you want from me i i
just don't want to get sick dude all
right then sit over there it's hey i'm
sitting over here but no i don't have
that i can't afford it you want me to
leave before the next episode
here goes
i can't get sick dude i'm gonna wait i'm
away five out of the next seven you want
me to film everything before the next
episode and then who happens who does
the next [ __ ] redhead just walked in
well you could do with him are you
filming us with those glasses are you
filming us with us
you and santino can do it and all the
fans can see how you shove me off my own
show
santino do i feel warm to you
he feels warm
yeah i'm not sick scaring off people no
i'm not scaring off people you know
what's speaking of sick you know what's
sick bacon egg and cheese is sick bro a
bacon egg of cheese is is
contagious
i think if he will
no
if he walked in and had a bacon egg and
cheese it's sick because i would want
one because it's contagious you see what
i did there i see what you said i'm at
least extrapolating here you look like
you are about to pass my back hurts what
do you want from me the socks look great
on you man i love the taste thank you so
much by the way merch is out folks
joey's wearing the taste buds uh what do
you call those babe socks
the old school tube socks that say taste
buds on them what a fun thing it's just
a show
yeah
socks that's fun stuff what do they call
those well too tube socks is what i was
looking for oh okay
um all right so the point is
this is the blt
by the way invented way before the i
feel like i should be charging you a
copay why because you're like you look
like you're the [ __ ] therapist the
blt i think was one of the first
sandwiches ever created oh that's
probably that'll check out all right
well look up look it up pimp are you
just making you are you just throwing
stuff in there
your time no i'm very serious says the
blt 1903 was in a cookbook for the first
time okay what about the bacon egg and
cheese 1982
i bet i love the 80s vh1
bacon egg and cheese it goes back to the
1800s in england what you had a bad day
you're [ __ ] [ __ ] there's a lie
but it didn't have bacon it only had the
egg on the roll for factory workers well
then that's not a [ __ ] bacon egg and
cheese saying that's the precursors
when did the bacon egg cheese
this is the article that was just egg on
a roll
1800s it's that's what's popping up
[ __ ]
it does say it's a new york staple
what is so funny you
why
there's so many reasons
you make me laugh
well i don't mean to laugh at you but
i'm loopy too you know but you make me
[ __ ] live
well i mean you know look i'm dehydrated
we had to do these today what do you
want from me why don't you go give
yourself a liquid iv or something
i took one this morning
shout out liquid iv uh you used to
promote with us now you don't let's do
it again i'm going to get some more
stuff let me get some water
yeah
i'll take water
yeah but i don't want to cut it
no
oh shut up
he said his back hurts
i'm dehydrated andrew i'm
you're gonna get other people dehydrated
i gotta travel you gotta get me sick
i'm not sick of dehydration you said you
feel sick i'm dehydrated you when you're
dehydrated you'll feel good yeah
it's for me it's something i need your
pants pulled
here it's so down hot yeah why are you
wearing jeans on a [ __ ] would you
eat
delicious sandwiches
you went to brian
oh okay
babe we'll do so just think about
something you really love and we'll talk
about it for a little while let me get
the [ __ ] out of here
sorry for all the f's today i'm uh
i'm not myself see you tv
cool
cool
i'm not sick i'm dehydrated
i don't think he's sick i i think he has
back pain and i think that he's
dehydrated i think he's crank crank city
i didn't drink water all weekend i'm
dehydrated
wait a minute wait a minute don't worry
then what are we gonna do we're gonna do
another two-parter these people are
going to have a [ __ ] connection
through the results with santino in the
corner what time is it where are we at
i mean i left you guys rolling you must
be at least 35 minutes no we didn't
start when you left you started 15
minutes after i just took 15 minutes off
okay all right
i don't know i don't know let's go to
the phone okay we'll go
we'll put the gas on the pedal we'll
step on it okay and
to do two anyway we then to do one more
this is toward the end of this one you
could do whatever you like
it's whatever you want it's really up to
you my love i'll do i'll honestly do
what you want i mean at this point just
sit down we'll do the right just sit and
then we'll do one and we'll do we'll do
results
but no if it's a 35 that's rough
well we got to go to the phones so read
us some phones and just get his opinion
and we'll close it all right all right
so we're going to go to the phones and
before that we'll get you a pin okay
it's blt versus bacon egg and cheese oh
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah you know all
about it
how are you feeling you think he's he's
the dead man walking that way go over
there
just lunch away from me feel my head i'm
not sick i'm not gonna touch you that's
insane why would i touch you if you
might be sick i'm traveling and i go to
go to europe if i get sick and then go
to europe my wife will kill me if i come
home sick yeah it'll be the end of it
it'll be the end of the year she'll go
getting over something by the way last
week i had a cold
a week ago i had a cold so maybe i have
a cold no you don't can you do me a
favor can you like do you think you're
sick
guys i don't know i don't i just i feel
dehydrated and shitty i don't know i'll
leave if you guys drink water [ __ ]
hangover he didn't drink last night no i
i had a couple drinks at dinner it's not
yeah i further dehydrated myself at
dinner that's what you're asking me yes
and i ate like a [ __ ] animal
and i'm dehydrated but you're still
sitting like [ __ ] humpty dumpty dude
holy [ __ ]
i've never met two hey all right you
never met two who nothing
the uh who'd you never meet
would you never meet two of us
yeah huh
you never met two what nothing don't
worry about it lean back
i was leaned back he's got to come off
zack you don't want me leaning forward
yeah i'm at tupac
huh i got to tell you it is more fun
this way doing it just making you feel
bad about it what if you have covert
i hope i do yeah i hope you do too but i
hope you die
and i won't because i'm athletic yeah no
you're not yeah [ __ ] oh my god you
ever see him play frisbee are you joking
you don't want to yeah you're
athletically i worry about yourself feel
bad about yourself do you think you
cannot get coped if you work out if you
work out you're less likely to have
severe symptoms joe look at that body
works out
that body babe
[Laughter]
that body baby make the fella is that
what you're saying
who sings that
all right what is it go
pimp i'm gonna i said i said right out
loud i'm gonna assume if he has covered
and i get him assume and he probably
will sue me
i'll swim yeah he said he would yeah
yeah
yeah
uh you know i don't doubt that you will
the blt is looking in on this and be
like oh man so you got the results for
it's blt who's bacon egg and cheese
myself yeah i can't even leave if you
guys do the next one without me because
i gotta lock this place up now it's a
catch-22
you wanted to open up a business and you
wanted to want to report the business
and you want to not drink order all
these three things add up to where you
are right now
it's pretty easy math it's probably the
easiest math i've ever heard one plus
one plus one equals i'm glad by the way
i'm glad we got chris done nice and
early as he's still sitting at the bar
out there
at 5 00 pm
have you ever heard such a lie as i have
to take my daughter to an mma class at 5
30.
unreal unreal could have done mine
banged him out went home rested
sitting here all day
all day chris is like i gotta i gotta
get out of here dude i got i can't be
here
he does this every time
oh that pig 450 right now chris you got
to go
what time is mma class
yeah because you know how there's no
traffic in new york at 5 00 p.m you get
around at 5 00 pm yeah
one fan writes in blt's are just water
what's that mean i guess the lettuce i
don't know
that's a dumb statement come on blts are
water so bacon egg and cheese versus blt
which would you take uh it's not it's
not even a competition really it's not
even remotely close you would take bacon
egg and cheese it's not even it's
honestly this is like kind of like a not
fair debate
bacon egg and cheese is and by the way
what what what bread are we even talking
about anyone who want baby bro that's
another problem i said english muffin
biscuit
if you said a bad bread with bacon egg
and cheese and then put your blt on
something superior then you might have a
conversation but just face-to-face
toe-to-toe it's just nuts i said bread
and bread wash bacon and bacon wash we
talked about this he's got lettuce and
tomato versus eggs and cheese and he
said would you say cheese would you call
cheese look at that dairy poultry meat
in bacon egg too much grease
no no it's the holy trinity
that's that dude you need all three you
need poultry dairy and you need meat
pork poultry
poultry why do you need chickens poultry
yeah eggs eggs yeah but why do you need
poultry on a sandwich protein
but vacant doesn't have a protein it's
all fat there's no protein like for
health reasons no i'm saying for an
all-around holy trinity of a good
sandwich it has all the things every
sandwich needs to have poultry on it and
he's got protein i'm saying it has a
protein in it you need protein bacon's
protein bacon is such a low amount of
protein it's mo it's almost all fat
common misconception then what purpose
does bacon serve deliciousness and
that's all it does that's fine but you
have to have somebody else to back up
the deliciousness okay why do you think
on a [ __ ] california chicken sandwich
they have the chicken chicken and the
[ __ ] bacon because california sucks
that's why we kicked you out yeah it was
the best day of my life when i say that
you know the truth you left you left
yeah you went guys i'm leaving everyone
what
yeah you were here
did you guys know joe was here
[Laughter]
when joe
i'm sorry i love you to death but i
gotta tell you this is tough it's just
too hard let me ask you a question
margin of victory but you're also
stepping into an arena of a guy that
[ __ ] breakfast food is my go-to
that's insane i i'm not a breakfast guy
what
what are you that what kind of guy can
you be lunch is my favorite lunch is
insane when you get older what do you
what what do people skip the most lunch
lunch gets cut out this doesn't matter
anymore uh i'm just not a big breakfast
guy when you get older a guy am i like
my dad he told me he was like why do i
need a lunch i'll eat a great breakfast
and then i'll take a walk i'll have a
couple of coffees then by the time it's
four or five i get to have a dinner
i'll eat breakfast or lunch for dinner
it's just about the time i can breakfast
all day yeah breakfast to me but it's
but it to me
it is
a filler meal
it's it's i think lunch is i eat
breakfast in the morning at lunchtime
condition of filler yeah but in between
them well some many days i won't eat
breakfast and then i'll just go to lunch
uh but other days when i'm healthy that
lunch is your breakfast yeah but other
days when i have you know what i mean
other days when i have like a true
breakfast
it's putting down fruit to like get
something down just so you're supposed
to have something about it yeah and
coffee and then i will often coast till
dinner but if you asked me my favorite
meal on paper
that if i could eat one of the types of
food for the rest of my life it would be
lunch when i said that over dinner
sandwich because lunch pulls in
breakfast and dinner from either side
dude
it's like lunch is such an array like
sandwich at dinner really is not a thing
sandwich at lunch is a thing you could
also have steak at lunch you could have
you could have pasta at lunch you could
there's so many lunch is so versatile
it's insane this sounds like when you're
talking to a kid it's like yeah you can
have anything at any time but you
probably shouldn't for the sake of the
health of your life look at a lunch menu
don't tell me it's not the most
versatile menu what does dinner not do
that lunch what is lunch that dinner
doesn't do take take for instance the
sandwich i mean the restaurant we're at
last year
what did it say next to the sandwiches
lunch time only yeah you know why
because they don't make that [ __ ]
for a delicious dinner guess what
everything else on that menu was
available at lunch too here's the point
a good dinner we don't even serve it
till 5 4 or 5 p.m they go we can't make
this yet it's too good you can't have
this you can't have this yet you can't
have this yet yeah lunch is saying you
can only have this from now to down
because we don't want to make it anymore
it's annoying
yeah
how does any of this uh make a blt beat
a big and against well it's a lunch
sandwich and sometimes i will eat it for
breakfast and if i did eat it for
breakfast it's superior to the bacon
when was the last time you had a blt
yeah all over it may all over no not
shopping just enough to moisten the
bread when was the last time you had a
blt
a week that is a lie joe don't smirk
we'd be dealing honesty here the trade
is honest why is it a lie because you
don't have a blt once a week you know it
when you said it i could tell i know you
i have about any amount i'm not dieting
if i'm not dieting i have about one a
week that's the truth if you're not what
dieting
i'm serious i was listening out of bacon
and cheese i can't even remember today
literally today but i had a sausage egg
and cheese on saturday margin of victory
is going to be out of 100 percentile
78 percent you wow cheese is better than
a ham egg and cheese
who are you pooling from new york new
york residents no no that's the thing
entire world
that's why we might you say world that's
so funny
bulgaria is showing up
[Laughter]
no you know what it is it's like it's
going to be la new york chicago a couple
big states so any big city person is
going to vote for bacon again i agree
with that but that's that's the if you
get some misnomers the middle of the
country may just may just go against the
grains because bacon egg and cheese is a
city food it's his only health you're
not getting bacon egg and cheese in a
lot of places you just don't it's all
right great that's why i think i'm going
to win pepe let's go you're not going to
win but i do think you're going to get
let's go to the phones and see what
people are saying well a common comment
is that a blt is like a shitty version
of a salad
and they're calling the bread croutons
oh i could see that's interesting okay
okay uh a lot of people hate tomatoes
despised tomatoes
i know people hate eggs though but are
there any i mean let's read those
comments though more people hate
tomatoes than eggs that's the problem
more way more people
i don't eat raw tomato
you don't touch it it's it's it's fine
but it's useless to me it's it's the
texture is [ __ ]
what am i doing with it i like a cooked
tomato of any kind cook it any kind
you're sick yeah go home
what are you doing down there
nothing i got what okay
you got now i'm so scared you guys are
mad at me because i didn't think i was
sick but now i'm getting worried because
you keep saying i'm sick that i'm sick
you told me you felt sick no i said i
didn't feel good santino i walk in you
go what's up but you go ugh i kind of
feel sick i don't know i don't verbatim
but i said i felt cause i logged it in
my panic brain because i said anxiety
went but i was saying i was dehydrated i
wasn't saying like yeah you said the
words i feel like we were on this
conversation a couple hundred times
today maybe dude
i don't know what to do we were painted
into a corner here right we had to
record i don't know i'm leaning this way
hard that's awesome
i wasn't trying to trick anybody i
thought it was dehydrated maybe i'm
[ __ ] sick i don't think you're
tricking anybody i think this was a
fruitful episode let's go to the phones
let's get a couple of zingers let's do
it
subscribe to the no press channel on
youtube if you want to do us a favor on
itunes you got a moment rate us follow
us on spotify you know the deal this is
ways to help our podcast with really
minimal effort merch is on sale now it's
there's some real hum dingers in there
now there's a lot of new stuff get to
merch and then you know tour dates we're
going right now south volcano county dot
com joe derosainfo.com interesting like
i'm not touring anymore but just come
say hi he's not to watch him in the
movies and on television he's a
superstar watch bad friends watch watch
whiskey ginger bad friends please
absolutely which joe's going to be on
when he comes to la in july and he's not
going to be sick for
yes that is true all right that is true
let's go to the phones please go to the
phones all right blt broken lazy tired
wait bro
tired or broken
uh broke broke lazy
they also call that sandwich
they're awesome i'm so not in the mood
for it just let him hit it yeah as
opposed to the elegance of the [ __ ]
bacon egg and cheese you [ __ ] pig
animals
all of you
i'm gonna give you a lot of credit on
this take it out i'm gonna give joe a
lot of credit on this bacon egg and
cheese is not a rich man's meal let's
not pretend that that's a that's an
astute king's meal versus the blt
if anything to be honest only on every
diner menu across the country bacon egg
and cheese not on one of them crazy talk
that's insane they're both on all of
them no some diners will have a
breakfast sandwich and they'll say
here's your choice of me no but it's
because the phrase bacon egg and cheese
is an inherent cultural thing we know
that's a cultural thing though it's
called a breakfast sandwich but it's a
bacon egg and cheese yeah the listeners
are really feeling your dehydrated ire
if i'm being honest with you it is fit
it is true i can't deny that well then
[ __ ] push it away let's speed through
this
let's keep stretching out the end a
little longer here
tomatoes are satan's hemorrhoids wow
keep going babe keep going uh you're
uh
if there's anything to say about bacon
and cheese's negative you could say it
as well if there's anything yeah uh
bacon egg and cheese is a the best new
york meal
that's negative yeah
the stefano is a blt and the roses of
bacon egg and cheese
no i will not clarify
okay should clarify that we would need
more information to find out what you're
trying to say that's negative or
positive yeah
uh if i see someone eating a blt i just
assume they're poor
what what is this what
let him go
let it go he hurt his back dude he got
so upset he hurt his back who says
things like this
[Laughter]
what else pimpy any other funny eggs are
a chicken's tampon
i knew people would take a shot at eggs
i was waiting for it
um
blt doesn't have cheese and therefore
can [ __ ] off
see and this is a big one your if cheese
is america is isn't such such a thing
americans love so much it's so tough
yeah it's why we're such a top-notch
country these days
you think cheese is our problem
it's just one what's going on in that
russia ukraine
it's got a lot to do with cheese
i'll tell you that it's just one of many
problems here cheese where it starts
there's one way to stop school shooters
give them more cheese
cheese those kids up jesus they won't be
going to school like that anymore if
they're cheese happy
um just a lot of blt hate honestly all
right i don't like that give us the
numbers doesn't seem good all right so
this is the humble pie segment
pimp is going to give us the results
right now all right uh
12 000 and who did you who you voting
for i'm going bacon egg and cheese okay
okay
oh okay okay wait before you say
anything oof means is it closer than we
thought no oh joey i don't understand
joey boy the pipes are pipes i truly
don't understand it's a classic sandwich
so the b uh blt came in at 33 percent oh
i was close i said 71
yeah i said 71 you 78 you said but you
were still close 78 70. you were still
very close 10 is a great good margin so
what is it then 33.67
so it's two thirds
it's two out of three people prefer
bacon egg and cheese
all right
i've never seen you i've never seen you
i've never seen you
just dwindle and accept a loss like i
can't yell because it hurts my back um
i'm not in the mood for these comments i
think they're way off base
i think it's insanity
insanity
that people went against a classic
staple sandwich like this i think the
idea
i think that this it's despicable that
people are saying equating a sandwich to
poor people and degrading poor people i
think that's really gross actually
and uh and here we are and then i look
forward to reading your complaints next
week that i wasn't high energy enough
for your free [ __ ] podcast
who is the favorite the guys the folks
that we love that keep the tallies we
haven't seen one in a while do me a
favor split it at the 52 let us know how
we're doing after 52 and where we stand
right now uh what else joey anything
else babe
no vegas i'll be there july 15th at the
version
but i'm also going to be at seattle
portland and vancouver and those are on
sale right now and i just announced 13
new cities they're all listed on
salvolcanocomedy.com coming up to canada
for the first time i'm coming to uh
north california florida all that good
stuff again check it out you all right
nice i still love you babe oh i can't
plug just you doing plugs oh i thought
you said you didn't want to do it we're
not supposed to do it at the end but you
seem to have no respect for them
why don't you do it at the end we do
them at the beginning and then he does
them again at the end and i'm like it's
too much plugging we didn't do it no we
don't do it with the beginning dates
dates at the beginning and the end are
fine all right fine
i will be coming to okay fine
well no cut it off now don't let you do
your dates you don't want to do it at
the end no no no no no no no no no i'm
dehydrated
we're both doing
i'll be in fairfield connecticut and
then i will be in san francisco
california and then i will be in los
angeles doing a show bring him water and
then i will be in atlantic city and then
i will be
up in somerville massachusetts i will be
in north carolina uh
uh i'll be in vegas go to
jodarossainfo.com for all ticket sales
come see me and come to joey rose's
open six days a week tuesday through
sunday joey thank you
thank you
joeyrosesnyc.com i'm sorry everybody
that i don't feel very well right now i
apologize so he doesn't feel well i
still love you babe
yeah
wow
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two foods gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds